you know people say Jeff Bezos isn't
generous but I've been on WhatsApp with
him for 10 minutes and he's sending me
money just gotta put in my social
security number real quick all right all
right that was a bit of a joke but it's
in honor of a new scam that we need to
talk about involving Jeff Bezos and
Amazon because it's all over YouTube
right now it's a crypto scam and here's
how it works recently you might have
seen something like this in a comment
section
these comments are everywhere thoughts
on AMZ 15v or comments about some big
pre-sale and you might be wondering what
this is all about well if you're curious
enough like me you'll search it and
here's what will come up a verified
YouTube channel called coin market cap
news now for context coin market cap is
a legitimate company that provides news
coverage stats on cryptocurrency when
you go to their homepage it seems like
they are associated they have real coin
market cap YouTube videos there so
because everything appears to check out
you might be tempted to watch the next
video when you do you'll hear about an
exciting new opportunity hey guys what's
up in today's coin market news episode
we talk about something that might be
the breaking news of the Year Amazon is
making the first moves to join the
crypto scene the US tech company under
CEO Jeff Bezos has opened up the
pre-sale for their new AMZ Amazon token
private investors can use Invitational
links which are currently available to
jump into the pre-sale to get some AMZ
before its planned launch in March or
April obviously this video is a bit
sketchy right but there's a piece of
your brain that's going to think man if
you could just be the first to invest in
an Amazon crypto it's going to be huge
however when you finally go to their
website this is where things start to
look a little scammy first of all
there's a giant timer to create a sense
of urgency there's the promise of 200
percent bonuses if you spend enough
money and when it's finally time to buy
a Bitcoin address is given to you to
deposit to supposedly they're going to
send you back some Amazon tokens or
whatever except that's never gonna
happen because Amazon and Jeff Bezos
aren't associated with this at all
you've been scammed what the hell is
even that but to understand how this all
works let's rewind how did they achieve
all of this you see this scam actually
exploits one of YouTube's features on
people's home pages see you can put your
own videos on your homepage but did you
know you can actually put another
Channel's videos there as well and these
scammers use this fact to highlight the
real coin market caps videos on their
scam Channel which they bought to that
subscriber count and they fake a
verification or whatever and then they
turn it into coin market cap news to all
give the illusion that they're
associated with this legitimate company
and then all they do is they upload a
single video which you can see on their
videos tab which is the scam video in
question and they buy a bunch of Bot
traffic and likes to the video to make
it seem popular then they don't stop
there they write positive comments they
don't let real comments through they
even buy fake likes and fake replies to
their fake comments and all of this
creates a mirage of real excitement
legitimacy and human activity but of
course this too is an illusion this is
all a trap for their viewers and so now
that the Trap is set how do you get
people to actually find this video this
is where the spam comments come in a
fake Channel like this would be
outranked by popular ones and
recommendations but by discussing
something really cryptic and specific
like AMZ 15v or AMZ 200v it sounds
vaguely financial and importantly it's
also specific enough to make sure that
if anyone searches it nobody else has
that keyword so only their scam video
shows up and it appears legitimate and
when I first saw this I was so taken
aback by all the work they put into this
it made me wonder who's on screen
endorsing it that's part of it a human
face that brings trust and I quickly
realized it's probably not one of the
actual scammers themselves but instead a
Fall Guy someone they hired and I
decided to find this person to a inform
them that they're being used for a scam
and B I wanted to confront them maybe
they can give us details on who hired
them for all of this so I spent the next
few hours combing through all the
popular freelancing sites and at first I
found nothing however on page three of
Fiverr when you search through the terms
Green Screen Actor I found a familiar
face a guy named Josh yep that looks
like him so immediately I messaged him
to try to get in touch and see what he'd
say and to my surprise he answered but
to my bigger surprise he mistook me for
someone else for that like TTI dot
social no this is for this is for that
Amazon it was like an Amazon commercial
basically like it was like Amazon crypto
coin or something okay have you tried
contacting me before I have not okay
yeah so I had someone trying to do this
recently and they saw like yeah I did a
video and they ended up using my photo
and said I was a developer and I was
like I contacted them and said hey take
that down so I thought that's maybe who
you were hmm apparently this has
happened before with Josh people
contacting him about a scam he's been
associated with I thought this was all
pretty strange and I'm even though I'm
sure he's being duped as we talked
through this he explained to me his
policy on these things and it made me
understand why this wasn't the first
time most video those were you know I
say something that I don't know is true
I start the video by saying that and
then they'll just edit it out and you
know that means I can prove hey when I
sent this video I did this and if they
edit it that that's wrong I'm not okay
with that but you know I don't know what
else to do about it wait what this guy's
policy about saying things he thinks
might not be true is just make a
disclaimer that he knows they're gonna
edit out anyways like what kind of
excuse is that yes I did know it was a
scam but did you see that disclaimer
that they edited out uh no because they
edited it out oh well I'm sorry I can't
be held responsible then I mean the
audacity to admit that what you do it's
just it's just kind of funny to me and
look to be fair to Josh uh you know I
didn't find any involvement Beyond just
like the five or higher so I don't want
to make it sound like he's some big
Mastermind I just want to point out how
sometimes people can just be complicit
by being lazy with their vetting besides
my main goal was to just try to find the
people behind him anyway so I didn't
really push the issue with him I really
wanted to know who paid him for this job
but this is where we hit another dead
end uh yeah I'm not seeing it in my
emails not sure what that means
they might not have gone under the
channel coin market news they might have
tried to like yeah so you might get a
script I my email body has the entire
script so if I search I should be able
to have an exact phrase and I should
just pull right up so I'm not sure why
that is but
okay if we take Josh's word he can't
find anything in his records now I asked
Josh if he wanted to be part of another
voice acting gig paid of course where um
he would basically be disavowing the ad
he just made for these guys uh but
unfortunately he told me he doesn't feel
like he's the best fit for this role
apparently Josh had started getting a
little more careful with the jobs he
took either way for now this case is
headed into the cold case files
fortunately we can't close it yet until
we know who's behind this but for now I
think there's only one thing left to do
after a Long Day's Work